yeah you know what welcome to this video
playing Frankie J let's see yeah that's
a kind of room and we get let's see what
we got here many sidelines nowadays III
and so on I should remove that but
they're usually you can do safely ok
let's go for the briar which I still
have not studied in much detail but yeah
my usual experience is that I play it
well enough that i'm not losing
instantly or getting into you trouble so
let's see
going for rupee eight Bishop f8y and why
this in time to consolidate a center and
like being kettles yeah black some a
piece set up is so yeah quite ammonius
in the in the brea really a good own
good very sound kind of setup okay let's
do this not sure but i don't want to
spend ages here try to figure out
something that it i don't know just try
to be quick about it ok so here i don't
know if i need to go to need to do to
them g7 here in the first place it's not
doing that much there anyway what I do
want to play is 95 and I am I'm a little
bit skeptical sometimes about positions
where 95 comes and why takes it and
black has to take with the deep on
rather I want to take with a piece of
possible so I'm playing it like this
just hoping that there is no drawback
and don't see one at the moment but
we'll see what happens
yeah white can keep tension you can play
okay one that Fisher maneuver from 1990
to return match in Yugoslavia first game
we had a comparable position of official
doubled on the a file behind the pawn
also what I'm trying to do is put the
night to be six to make make sure that
white is declaring his attention there
something that irritates me as a
possible hmm yeah stuff like that my
king site is really am yeah not well
defended okay let's go here and if 94 I
go to h5
now the bishop helps on g7 a bit to
cover f6 and possibly open up if he goes
f4 at is that it is looking at the e5
square yeah this thing yeah the thing is
that you can sometimes even secular
sacrifice there
and I'd be six or seven to clarify that
but my king side I'm kind of afraid to
admit could easily easily backfire
okay h5 so going to 90 here first and
then see what happens here yeah night
shift guy is playing this first maybe I
have to go back here to cover to
something kappa g phone
all right maybe bishop q1 or something
oh okay that gives me t 3 in some cases
adds an extremely complex position maybe
it's bad for me that it's very much
possible actually I don't feel like this
went too well but it is definitely a
complicated position so it's something
well the better player can often do
things because there's simply so much
going on the better player I know me
knowing who I mean the site who plays
better really can can can benefit him
which is not so clear and some other
kind of positions where simply nothing
happens and yeah and you can play
whatever you want it's still be equal
now he's got 94 coming up I will have to
play h5 then that this is really it's
really ugly
I need some defensive pieces yeah not a
happy move maybe I can still defend this
Bishop situ yeah if for was attacked to
time to do this now g4 actually trades
more let's do that even though the night
on h2 is not great but it might come to
add 32 g 5 so maybe that trade helps a
little bit to make my defense easier
it might not be so bad now okay tries to
go me but I can always take it so not
the other big issue what about this
group them to cannot somehow trade it
can this route b7r okay seven now maybe
want to trade the rope to prevent any
invasion them night comes to h3 I just
take it maybe g4 is a move g4 can be
interesting maybe whoa okay okay so
please please trade and it doesn't okay
yes I have to take I wonder if night Eve
for my p mov n 94 it's it's me it's a
try at least to make things interesting
on c4 I have Knight to c3 maybe ok now
I've got a passer and not sure how much
what it is worth but something ok I'm
sure you should age six would trade the
bishop quite reliably I don't know if
it's any good to be honest let's take it
let's do that let's try that now here i
have checked at a 3 you've a d6 is
hanging I can do this and create six
that sends an interesting and cover this
and now let this run and I it's got
little time check oh ok cannot let them
enter ok let's grab I just glad
resilience I even lose some time he will
lose on time wow I'm not sure what this
was probably not so great very
complicated middle game though around
here I think this is a theoretical
position or close to it so I went here
and I didn't want to play 95 immediately
so here let's see five here I think it
just it is somewhat risky what I'm doing
here maybe computers on 000
yeah but I feel like I'm playing a risky
way here yeah somewhat it keeps about
equal 0.34 white doesn't see anything
terrible happening to me check no it
doesn't like that computer wants to go
pick up t 1 mm waiting with this it's my
maybe an idea check okay I could have
played H Froy I didn't I didn't think
about that little snatching head porn no
I didn't think about that at all still I
have aged for I didn't I didn't I was
just concerned with the heck not
allowing some kind of sacrifice they are
I was happy to be safe let's say and I
didn't think about and winning that porn
you know Jackie that was an ok game the
computer gives foolish things all the
way and no I'm for the first time
clearly better and he resigned with the
clock about to run out probably it was
equal yeah I round equal the time I had
my doubts because my my maneuvers looked
a little bit a little bit unkind to work
in position but it seems there there
wasn't any any direct way to refute it
ok hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching